Yesterday, as I've been following the terrible
situation in Texas because of a winter storm,
people lacking power, some lacking heat and
more. I came across a Ted Cruz tweet that I
found suspicious. This is Republican Texas Senator
Ted Cruz who tweeted, quote, Today, Senator John
Cornyn and I sent a letter to President Biden
urging for Governor Abbott's emergency federal
disaster declaration request to be approved amid
severe winter storms across the state of Texas.
Now, when I saw this, I had an inkling that,
wait a second, I remember Ted Cruz in the past
when the natural disasters were in some other
part of the country that he doesn't represent.
I remember Ted being against disaster declarations
and federal money for the affected states.
So I went back into the archives and found that,
yes, Ted Cruz really is a disgusting hypocrite on
this issue. Back in 2012, when Hurricane Sandy
ravaged the northeast of the United States,
states like New York and New Jersey, Ted
Cruz voted against providing federal aid
to those Northeast states. Why did he vote against
it? While he said that the bill was symptomatic of
spending money we don't have in Washington, D.C.,
but then in 2015, when there were floods in Texas,
Ted Cruz wanted federal money for them.
And then in 2017, when hurricanes hit Texas,
suddenly Ted Cruz wanted federal money for Texas
for that. And this actually came up on MSNBC
back in twenty seventeen. Check this out.
But a lot of people are pointing out that
you voted against aid for Sandy after that
catastrophic catastrophic storm up in the
Northeast, that package back in 2012. And they're
pointing at you and saying you're asking for money
now when you weren't willing to help the people
in the Northeast. What do you have to say to them?
Well, you know, look, there's time
for political sniping later. I think
our focus needs to be on this disease.
That's right. It isn't political sniping.
It's a pretty simple question of it appears
that you can be counted on to push for money,
for disaster relief for your state, but to stand
in the way of similar moneys for non constituents.
And eventually Ted Cruz gives an
answer. It's a completely bogus one.
These are people who needed money and who needed
funding. Right after that storm, I covered
those people, many of them, just like those in
Houston, lost absolutely everything they owned.
Well, Katie, Katie, of course. That's right.
And the accurate thing to say is that I and a
number of others enthusiastically and emphatically
supported hurricane relief for Sandy. Hurricane
relief and disaster relief has been a vital
federal role for a long, long time, and it
should continue. The problem with that particular
bill is it became a fifty billion dollar bill
that was filled with unrelated pork. Two thirds
of that bill had nothing to do with Sandy.
And what I said then and still believe now is
that it's not right for politicians to exploit
a disaster and people are hurting to
pay for their own political wish list.
Disaster relief needs to be focused on the
victims of disaster relief. And I supported that
for Sandy disaster relief there. And I would
support that anywhere. There's a major disaster
without getting getting distracted by
my political unnecessary pork spending.
Oh, that bill had pork. I OK, I see he's
disgusting. And in fact, PolitiFact looked
at this and it's a talking point that Republicans
often used in their in defending their opposition
to funding relief for Hurricane Sandy.
Some of them would say
50 of the 60 billion in that bill is pork or two
thirds of it is pork or 90 percent of it is pork.
But the truth is that it was all lies. Now, it's
not actually exactly clear how much of the bill
from 2012 was specifically for disaster relief
for Sandy because there was money in there
for mitigation of future disasters. And as
usual, there is some pork, but that's business
as usual. That has nothing to do with where the
disaster is. That's sadly how Congress works.
It's horrible, but it's many of Ted Cruz. His own
Republican colleagues who were responsible for
a bunch of that pork being in the 2012 bill, but
here's the key thing. When you talk about disaster
relief, it should be part of it to prepare for
the next one. When we talk about coronavirus now
and the package that Democrats now want to get
through, it includes money for rebuilding some
of the infrastructure that Donald Trump destroyed,
getting rid of the pandemic response team,
throwing out the playbook, all of these different
things if we don't take steps to harden and make
systems more robust. This is just going to happen
again. And the idea that that's why Ted Cruz voted
against it is absolutely insane. Now, let me
be super clear. I don't want to punish people
of Texas because Ted Cruz is a hypocrite. I
want the people of Texas to get the money.
I just want Ted Cruz not to oppose disaster relief
when it comes to some other state, but defiantly
defend it when it's his own state. That's what's
pathetic here. And Ted Cruz has a long history of
doing this. Many Republicans have a lot you we're
talking about Ted Cruz now because he's involved
in this because it's his state now. But the same
thing happened in I'm going from memory here, but
I believe it was in Oklahoma because of tornadoes
when there were Republicans that were saying,
of course, we need the declaration in Oklahoma,
we need the federal relief money in Oklahoma. They
had voted against Sandy relief in 2012 for New
York and New Jersey. I believe Tennessee. I mean,
we'd have to look at the full list. But this
is a type of hypocrisy that is not rare in the
American right and it's absolutely destructive.
Ted Cruz is as disgusting as the rest of them